Ne touchez à rien p*tain !
C'est le nom du jeu
Et là, c'est le remake 3d. Voilà, il est tout beau, tout lisse, tout propre, c'est parti !
ON VA TOUT TOUCHEEEEER !!!!!!!!!!!
Ah moi tu me dis de pas faire un truc
j'ai envie de le faire de ouf
juste pour te faire chier
Donc on est là, y a ce p*tain de panneau devant nous
ok pendant que le mec se douche
Et on sait pas euh... où on est, on sait pas ce qu'il y a
Donc ya un bouton, on va toucher le bouton.
Ça ouvre ça
Ooooooooohhh.....
*bruit de sirène*
M*rde
Oh m*rde la violence !
Je rappuie sur le bouton du coup ?
OH !
Y a d'autres trucs qui apparaissent ?
3 2 1 (dit un peu rapidement)
*bruit un peu faible d'une explosion*
Oh merde j'ai déclenché une bombe nucléaire mec !
Eh c'est peut-être le moment que tu reviennes de ta douche mec !
Pendant ce temps...
Lalala, laaa (chante)
"I love mushrooms"
Moi j'aime les bien les champ...
C'est mon ventre ça ? Ah non c'est une chaise !
J'ai carrément cru que ce mec était... Gérard Depardieu
Qu'est-ce que je fais avec ça ?
AH ! (fort)
Je le colle sur le mur. D'accords !
Ah c'est la première fin je suppose ? Ah ouais, regardez ça recommence. Il y a plusieurs fins.
D'accord, c'est ça ! Et le but ça va être de trouv... P*tain mais il y a tout ça comme fins là ?
Sans déconner ?
Euh est-ce qu'il y a moyen de pas tout faire péter ? Genre, juste appuyer sur "reset" ?
(bruit musical de "reset" qui se répète en rythme)
Les Daft Punk mec, ils ont commencé comme ça. Alors, ne me juge pas s'teplaît.
Euh, bah du coup, j'ai plus du tout envie d'appuyer sur ce bouton. Je ne veux vraiment pas tuer des gens avec une bombe nucléaire...
Mais je crois mec qu'il n'y a rien d'autre à faire en vrai...
Ah si il y a un livre là ! 8...2...67...
= d
8267 on retient.
Ça, je peux pas ouvrir, là ya un joystick, je ne peux pas le prendre, la ya une imprimante...OH !
Ça imprime des choses ?
"Correct..." Ok donc si on le prend dans le bon sens, ça fait...
En bas à gauche, en haut à gauche, en haut à gauche, en bas à gauche.
Bah attends, c'est peut-être un truc à faire avec le joystick qu'il y a juste là justement...
Non c'est un tampon, c'est pas un joystick ! Lucas, arrête cette addiction aux jeux vidéos !!
Bon mec, vas-y un moment on est obligé, ya pas 36 solutions.
Si je rappuie... OH !!!
Si je rappuie dessus, au lieu de déclencher celui là, ça fait ça.
1 + 2, 3 (en rythme)
2 + 3, 5 (toujours en rythme)
Ya pas de 5. Ah bah non !
312211, c'est ça !
3, 1, 2, 2, 1, 1.
Mais non ! Mais c'est marqué là ! Arrêtez de mentir aussi !
Eh ! Ya une flèche là ! Je l'avais pas vu, regardez !
J'ai recommencé et il y avait cette flèche que je n'avais pas vu !
Oh non ! Mec il y avait un truc à faire ! C'était une autre énigme !
Oh, en spammant ! Ça a ouvert un truc avec un tournevis ! Qu'est-ce que je fais avec ce tournevis mon gars ?
Euh... Il y a un truc à dévisser quelque part. Ah là ! Il y a des visses là ! P*tain..
VOILÀÀÀÀ !!!!!
Ah j'aime bien me prendre pour l'inspecteur Squeezie !
(bruit de hamster)
(bruit de robot)
Le mec, fait notamment des expériences sur des hamsters à mi-temps. C'est normal dans ce bureau
Non, on n'aura plus besoin du tournevis...
Ah si, euh là, pour dévisser ça...Bah oui !!
Il n'y a pas des hamsters là-dedans ? Non...
4 boutons ! Il n'y a pas un rapport avec ces couleurs là ? Attends...
Il y a vert, rouge, bleu, jaune. Mec c'est sur c'est ça non ?
OH SI !!
Pourquoi ? Ça veut dire quoi ça ?
Ok et à gauche, il y a un marteau. C'est pour enfoncer un truc ça ? L'écran ?
(bruit de brisure de l'écran)
(silence)
(rire)
Mais fait pas faire ça avec les télévisions mec ! Ça ça n'arrive que quand tu lâches ta Wiimote sans faire exprès parce que t'es un blaireau !
(bruit cosmique)
I-LU-MI-NA-TI (musique)
O-TA-TÉ (anglais déformé)
Bah voilà la deuxième fin, la fin illuminati ! C'est bien ça !
C'était effrayant mec
Cette ambiance était très pesante .
Bon, moi mec j'suis attiré par ça là
par cette flèche là. Le blème c'est que si je touche autre chose ça va le.. le
le rattirer. Peut être faire ça,
tu sais c'est le seul truc où y'avait des flèches
"correct" , bas-gauche, bas-droite... j'sais pas quoi
Ouais mais on n'a qu'une flèche... Donc je pense qu'y a d'autres trucs à faire pour faire apparaîte d'autres flèches,
en fait. Je pense hein !
Bon si on prend les choses dans l'ordre
est-ce qu'on essayerait pas de resoudre l'énigme du 1,2,3 qu'y a là.
C'est une combinaison de combien de chiffres, 6 chiffres ... ce qui fait 6*6*6*6*6*6 combinaisons
Voilà on va pas se faire chier à taper 46 000 combinaisons  possibles
Non mais voilà
1+1, 2...1+2, 3
3-2, 1... 1+2, 3
(rire)
On dirait un attardé !
Moi j'pense que nos plus grandes possibilités à quelque chose là c'est le truc des couleurs parce qu'y a que 4 euuh... ch... trucs à remplir
Donc ça fait 4 x 4 x 4 x 4 nombre de possibilités
Donc c'est moins élevé que 6 x 6 x 6 x 6... c'est super chiant...
Ok, donc là, j'sais pas moi... euh...
Bleu, rouge, rouge, jaune...
Vert, bleu, bleu, rouge...
Vert, vert, vert ,vert
Bleu, bleu, bleu, b...
"2 semaines plus tard"
Rouge, bleu, vert, vert...
Vert, rouge, bleu, bleu...
Vert, rouge, rouge, jaune...
Jaune, rouge, bleu, rouge...
(bruit métallique)
OH !!
J'sais même pas c'que j'ai fais !
(rire)
Woah j'y croyais même pas
Eh franchement j'pouvais faire ça pendant une heure !
Ça m'amusait de ouf !
Après j'me dis est-ce j'ai vraiment trouvé une combinaison ?
Ou alors est-ce c'est juste parce que j'ai eu faux 30 fois que y a ça qui s'est passé ?
Je sais pas
Tout n'est que sorcellerie et complot...
Nan j'pense vraiment que ça c'est quand j'me foire trop d'fois
Voilà, donc du coup j'me suis exclamé pour rien...
Et si avec le marteau je pète cette m*rde ?
(bruit d'alarme)
wtf ?
WTF ?!
WTF ?!!
Mais c'est quoi ce bébé en chocolat ?
Mais va-t-en sorcellerie !!
Fruit du démon !!
Eh le mec il va sortir d'sa douche il va halluciner
Il va croire que j'me suis goinfré de Twix et de Snickers
Mais non c'est un bébé en chocolat mec qui est apparu !
Il s'cachait dans ton bouton
J'l'ai tué ça y est, il est mort...
il est mort...
Plus personne ne pourra jamais lancer de bombe nucléaire
C'est la fin ?
Eh ben ouais c'est la fin...
Eh bah voilà une fin en plus, boom qu'est'ce tu vas faire ?
Bon moi j'veux trouver la fin avec les chiffres
Ça là
Mec c'est sûr c'est... c'est ça là
3 1 2 2 1 1
(bruit de boutons)
M*RDE !
j'ai (imcompréhensible) et j'aurais pas du.
"DON'T DO IT"
Alors déjà... déjà tu... tu vas redescendre
parce qu'un jour un grand sage a dit
"DO IT !!"
Et il a raison !
Alors mec euuh...
voilà, voilà, voilà, voilà...
J'sais pas c'que ça fait
"Invalid pattern"
Bah j'm'en bats les c*uilles
Ça c'est quoi c'est un levier ?
Eh ben boom mon pote
Oh p*tain
Attends il a tout ça dans son contrôle de...
Mais c'est quoi son travail exactement à ce mec j'comprends pas
C'est faire un casse-tête chinois grandeur réelle
et faire genre à ton pote que tu vas t'doucher alors que tu veux juste lui péter l'cerveau ?
C'est ça ton travail ?!
Bon du coup y a 3 7 0 0
ou alors 8 2 6 7
c'est les deux trucs que j'vois hein euh... clairement
C'est un code en 4 chiffres
c'est pour ça que j'dis ça
3, 7, 0, 0
Nan...
8, 2, 6, 7
ooooooh...
(rire)
non mais ça mec
on appelle Madéon on lui d'mande de faire un mix à c'moment là
(Musique)
Nan sans déconner mais faut pas croire qu'ça c'est...
si j'appuie d'ssus j'suis sûr ça fait un bruit d'batterie
(bruit de batterie)
Bah voilà
C'est faux c'est du montage...
"36 semaines plus tard"
Attends j'viens d'voir un gars sur YouTube, le mec il est trop chaud
il dit "donc là avec ce launchpad aux 6 milliards de combinaisons possibles
on va faire l'étoile satanique que y a sur l'tableau"
ça n'a aucun sens
C'est quoi c'est ça, ça, ça...
Oh !
C'est quoi c'délire mon gars ?
Ah ouais on part vraiment sur un sale délire là
un sale délire mon gars
Y a du sang qui coule des murs
l'heure passe euh plus vite
Est-ce qu'on a un papier ?
Oui on a un papier !
Nouvelle fin !
J'aimerais trouver la fin qui... euh...  avec ce papier là...
Avec la combinaison
J'aimerais trop trouver... Mais j'pense que c'est vraiment ça part sur ça là
cette petite flèche mec
c'est sûr...
Attends, qu'est-ce qu'on a fait tout à l'heure ?
C'était pas euh...
3 2 1 1 2 3
nan
Attends c'était 3 1 2 2 1 3
Voilà
Peut-être mec qu'en fait ça
c'est bon ça j'sais pas trop
Mais non !
P*tain le con !
J'me disais peut-être que ça en fait c'est... ça indique ça
donc dans l'bon c'est sens c'est bas-gauche, haut-gauche, haut-gauche
bas-gauche
Oh oui !
Ça a marché !
Qu'est-ce qui s'passe ?
Ah c'est un UFO
WTF ?
C'est la fin "UFO"
Les gens hurlent
Moi j'suis dans mon bunker j'm'en bats les c*uilles hein
Baptiste ça va toi ?
Lalalaa (chante)
"Reset"
Est-ce qu'on a un papier ?
Ouiiii !!
Le papier "UFO" !
Il est cool ce jeu !
Eh y a 30 p*utains de fins mon gars !
Vous vous rendez compte ?
C'est énorme mec !
Le nombre de trucs qu'on peut faire quand même au niveau des possibilités !
C'est ouf
(bruit de porte)
Oh !
Ah !
Donc quand tu fais rien pendant 3 minutes ou 5 minutes
ou j'sais pas combien de temps
...
c'est bon, t'as gagné une fin
La fin euh...
(rire)
Maître Zen qui a réussi à ne rien toucher
Ben mec
parfait !
Bon la révélation c'est j'suis pas resté là 4 minutes à rien foutre
j'étais en train de checker une vidéo d'un mec
pour voir si y a des fins drôles
(rire)
Aah ! me tappez pas !
Bon voilà les gens c'est déja la fin d'cette vidéo
sur "Please don't touch anything" !
J'espère qu'ça vous a plu
et qu'vous n'avez rien touché sinon c'est la fessée mon pote !
n'hésitez pas à l'aimer si elle vous a plu !
Mais c'est trop marrant ce jeu
qu'y ait 30 fins possibles
et qu'le but c'est de trouver soit même les 30 fins possibles !
but qui est
quasiment impossible !
Non mais c'est vrai !
Ben écoutez j'vous mets au défi d'le faire !
Sans regarder la vidéo du mec
comme j'étais en train de... de  faire honteusement !
(rire)
Nan j'avoue j'aime bien les jeux d'énigmes
Mais euh quand j'fais une vidéo là franchement
pour trouver... pour en trouver plus de 10
j'pense qu'il faut jouer au moins une heure et demie, deux heures
mais vraiment
et encore faut être doué quoi
Là on parle de Squeezie on parle pas de... hein...
Le mec il en trouve 1 il est content
A très bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir regarder portez-vous bien
Ciao tout l'monde
PEACE !
Ouais j'tentais un truc ouais...
(Outro de folie)